así que hemos terminado o al menos eso
espero de obtener la intuición de por
qué mi presión inicial por el volumen
inicial entre la temperatura inicial es
igual a la presión final de igual lo
mejor aquí podría ser algunos trucos
algebraicos pero bueno es igual a la
presión final por el volumen entre la
temperatura final y otra vez sólo hay
que recordar esto que la presión por el
volumen es proporcional a la cantidad de
energía cinética del sistema y la
temperatura es proporcional a la
cantidad de energía cinética por
molécula verdad si no cambiamos el
número de moléculas la cantidad bueno
como como se conserva la energía verdad
estamos suponiendo que se conserva la
energía que no estamos metiendo ningún
trabajo extra entonces esta relación se
cumple verdad esto lo vimos en el último
vídeo y espero que ya haya quedado muy
claro antes de aplicar esta ecuación
esto es lo que esto es lo que nos va a
llevar muy lejos en la termodinámica ok
eso y obtener la intuición de lo que
esto significa
y quiero clarificar un poco algo porque
hay muchas hay muchas formas de medir la
temperatura por ejemplo tenemos la
escala fahrenheit no que por ejemplo 32
grados fahrenheit eso es a la
temperatura cero grados celsius que es
cuando se congele el agua verdad así es
como se determinó los grados celsius 0
grados es cuando se congela y 100 grados
es cuando empieza a hervir el agua ok
podría ser estar más frío que eso verdad
no no es así como que el límite en el
cómo se calculan o como se determinó los
grados fahrenheit eso no estoy del todo
seguro me parece que fue con con
temperaturas este del cuerpo por ejemplo
212 es a lo que hierve el agua en
fahrenheit pero bueno no quiero hacer
más esta adivinanza es mejor habría que
buscarlo en la wikipedia pero bueno así
es como se empezaron a construir estas
escalas de temperatura verdad entonces
los 100 grados celsius es donde empieza
a hervir el agua 0 grados cuando se
congela
pero no podríamos decir como tal que que
esto no sea del todo útil verdad porque
podríamos ser que estemos dividiendo
entre 0 más aún esto por ejemplo tómense
un grado celsius y tómense de 100 grados
celsius no podemos decir que 100 grados
celsius es como que que haya 100 veces
más energía cinética que que cuando
tengo un grado celsius verdad entonces
realmente este este grado no es una
centésima parte de cuando está hirviendo
el agua verdad simplemente es una escala
que tomaron a partir del punto de
ebullición y de congelación del agua
pero bueno después los científicos
empezaron a preguntarse si habría algún
punto en donde empezar es decir un punto
en donde las moléculas tuvieran
absolutamente nada de energía cinética
porque dijimos que la temperatura d era
igual al promedio el promedio de la
energía cinética del sistema
o el total de energía cinética entre el
número de moléculas verdad es decir la
energía cinética por molécula
así que la única forma de realmente
decir que la temperatura es cero es es y
hay por cierto esto es proporcional
verdad porque la temperatura es
proporcional a estas unidades aunque
pero entonces la única forma de obtener
una temperatura igual a cero debería ser
cuando la energía cinética de cada
molécula fuera cero o que el promedio es
ceo es cero verdad es decir no se mueven
no vibran no hacen nada estas moléculas
están estacionarias y el punto en donde
eso ocurre se le llama como el cero
absoluto
0 absoluto y eso ocurre de hecho el cero
absoluto que también se le llama como
los cero grados kelvin que es lo mismo
que menos 273 menos 273 grados celsius
entonces a ningún lado en el universo o
al menos hasta donde yo sé se puede
estar más abajo de los 273 grados
celsius y esa temperatura nada se mueve
incluso en la escala atómica ok estoy
hablando que los electrones se colapsan
en el núcleo de todo está completamente
fijo en cero grados kelvin y ese es un
límite teórico no es que a lo mejor
hagamos vídeos de cómo podemos
acercarnos a eso en el laboratorio o en
el espacio exterior pero pero bueno este
realmente es un límite teórico estoy
seguro de que en ningún lado del
universo tenemos un cero grados kelvin
un cero absoluto podría estar equivocado
tales pero bueno esta es como mi deber
ay eso
yo estoy pensando al respecto entonces
la forma realmente de medir la
temperatura es en grados kelvin porque
cuando miden 100 grados kelvin digamos
que si yo tengo un grado que elvin
contra 5 grados kelvin como ya tenemos
un 0 fijo un punto de partida entonces
puedo
decir o afirmar que esto tiene esto
tiene cinco veces la energía que si
tuviera un grado kelvin ahora sí es
proporcional así que toda esta
explicación sobre kelvin
y me llega me sirve para llegar a
utilizar esta fórmula debemos convertir
a grados kelvin para poder utilizar una
temperatura entonces digo a lo mejor lo
tenemos en grados celsius o lo queremos
en grados celsius pero tendríamos que
hacer una conversión posterior entonces
espero que haya sido un poquito claro de
por qué es todo esto vamos a hacer un
ejemplo
vamos a hacer un ejemplo
antes déjenme borrar todo esto es esto
les puede sorprender de hasta dónde nos
puede llevar pero el punto central es
convertir todo a grados kelvin esta es
una de las razones de por qué muchos te
tienen mal sus ejercicios en exámenes de
termodinámica y es porque no convierten
a grados kelvin ok entonces como verán
realmente quizás el problema más difícil
sería hacer esa conversión este problema
nos dice que si tengo un gas confinado
en y digamos que tiene una temperatura
inicial de 27 grados celsius ok y tiene
una presión de 1000 pascal es
tiene una presión inicial de 1000 pascal
es o que también los conocemos como
newtons por x por metro cúbico verdad
y el volumen es d
el volumen es de 30 metros 30 metros
cúbicos entonces no sé no sé cómo nos
dicen en los vídeos anteriores pero
recuerden que los pascuales son newtons
por metro cúbico y luego dice que el
volumen se se esté apachurra este
nuestro nuevo volumen va a ser de 20
metros cúbicos entonces bajamos el
volumen la nueva temperatura se aumenta
así que la nueva temperatura es de 50
grados celsius lo que quieren saber es
cuál es la presión actual
entonces antes de que sustituyamos en la
ecuación nuestra nueva presión y demás
vamos a convertir los grados celsius en
kelvin si tendieron en fahrenheit
entonces conviertes a celsius y después
conviertes a kelvin correcto pero lo que
ya sabemos es que los cero grados kelvin
son 273 celsius verdad menos 273 otra
forma de decirlo es que si yo tengo x
grados kelvin esto va a ser
esencialmente los grados que tienes en
celsius simplemente le sumas 273 tiene
sentido otra forma de decir esto es que
los cero grados celsius
ok cero grados celsius esos ya son 273
grados
arriba del cero absoluto es decir es 273
grados kelvin entonces simplemente si
tenemos una temperatura en grados
celsius le sumamos 200 273
entonces esto será 273 más 27 que son
300 grados kelvin y 50 van a ser le
sumamos 273 y tenemos 50 más eso es 323
grados kelvin así que ahora si podemos
sustituir en la fórmula entonces la
presión 1 es 1000 pascal es por el
volumen que son 30 metros cúbicos
dividido entre 300 verdad 300 y esto es
igual a la presión 2 que es lo que no
sabemos por el el volumen que en este
caso aquí era el volumen 2 verdad el
volumen 2 es 20 y dividimos entre sin
323 que es la temperatura ahora que
hacemos este lado dividimos entre 100 y
quitamos estos dos ceros
entonces quitamos este 3 y quitamos este
3 de aquí y lo que nos queda son si en
verdad 10 por 10
entonces en realidad era 30.000 dividido
entre 300 y eso nos da simplemente si en
verdad del lado izquierdo entonces
tenemos 100 va a ser igual a la presión
por 20 entre 323 entonces déjenme
hacerlo acá arriba porque ya se me está
acabando el tiempo y si resolvemos
tenemos 323 por cien y esto lo dividimos
entre 20 y eso nos da mil 615 pascal es
mil 615 pascales y sólo resolvía esta
ecuación la parte difícil fue convertir
a kelvin nos vemos